hey everybody welcome to the great big
story YouTube channel this is Jillian hi
Dave
hi let's get the show in today's episode
we're going to show you four great big
stories that's all about the sky for our
first story we're going to meet a young
woman who is doing a new take on
skydiving indoors my way of expressing
myself is always been physical my mom
told me that since I was little it's
like if I would be angry or happy or
whatever you would see it in my body
language for me having a new way of
challenging my buddy a new way of
pushing the limits of what my body can
do that was the thing that really got me
hooked in flying my name is Inga Vesta
and I'm a dancer and a world champion
indoor skydive
I started dancing when I was three years
old and as long as I remember our bit
disease when indoor skydiving came along
I found something for the first time
that I was more passionate about than I
ever was about dancing suddenly I
realized like I've just found in your
way of dancing is just on a different
kind of decibels the discipline that I
can feed in is called freestyle but when
I'm speaking about my flying overall I
prefer to use the term air dancing
because it's not just about competing
and that sector Sizzlin it's about
creating something new exploring the
limits of what we can do in flying and I
would like to take flying from being a
sport towards being a form of performing
arts flying for sure is way harder than
it looks like the wind speeds can go up
to 180 miles an hour you have to be
strong you have to be flexible a lot of
the body positions look easy but they
actually require a lot to perform that
nicely so a split for example it might
look like I'm just resting in in that
flexible body position but I'm actually
all the time pushing against the airflow
to have control
I don't always like the use of the word
talented because it makes it sound like
only if you have that talent before you
even start flying you're going to get
good I've always been like a hard word
for myself so if I really want to get
good at something I'm going to do
whatever it takes it just depends on how
much you want
you
[Music]
hey Jillian have you ever thought about
living in a plane no well this next guy
has and then he actually did it let's
meet him jet liners are basically flying
hopes it's a sealed pressure canister
it's incredibly strong it will last
practically forever
[Music]
I'm Bruce Campbell and you're inside the
cockpit area of my 727 home I can
appreciate that some folks might feel a
bit isolated or it might simply strike
them as an unusual in an environment but
for me it's always felt completely
natural your entry is VOD after stairs
which are retractable and are retracted
would arrive leave for an extended time
the afteri of the aircraft now is my
living space my very primitive shower is
located there to natural after
laboratories are both functional
sleeping quarters there in the form of a
simple futon sofa and bench where I
spend lots of time embellishing elements
of the aircraft jet liners retired the
rate of about three per day for the most
part I think we shred them and then we
spin around 180 degrees and make a home
after having just shredded an aerospace
class home size structure if you are an
extraterrestrial looking down on this
behavior you'd wonder whether the
species has all its marbles in place or
not people have asked me whether it
crashed here and I simply restored the
wreck that's an odd thing to hear it's
completely impractical
next time you're in a jetliner close
your eyes for a moment in your mind
remove all the seats and all the other
people and then open your eyes with that
vision and consider the expanse of the
living room it's a good environment it
really is Dave yeah
have you ever built a plane yeah that
doesn't count I want you to meet this
guy named Ivo who built his own DIY
plane and he used it to escape the Iron
Curtain this here is a darkling beetle
it lives out here in the vast desert of
Northwest Utah and he's on the move
where - I don't have a clue but I can
tell you about the town he's leaving
behind
welcome to loose in Utah there's
abandoned cars weeds once in a while
train will pass through yep there's not
a whole lot here in loosen well except
for this man
[Music]
but who is this man this man who lives
in an airplane hangar who flies a Cessna
to get to his closest friend who is this
man this man who lives in the middle of
nowhere who was 25 miles from this bar
was this man inside who owns a bunch of
guns works with machines and made this
thing who is this man
my name is Ivo dhatus K and this is what
I live as you've gathered this man isn't
from around loosen he grew up in
Czechoslovakia before the fall of the
USSR you didn't like it much it's kind
of hard to do anything the Communists
were empowered of that you cannot have
your own business it's kind of difficult
to fly there so I can I didn't feel like
I could be myself you really wanted to
leave the country but it wasn't easy
there was an Iron Curtain they like have
a machine gun towers and barbed wire to
keep you in they like to keep you so
when he was 24 he escaped the country
the only way he knew how
by flying across the border and his self
built airplane so I drove up close to
the border between Austria and some time
like at 3 o'clock in the morning I took
off and I just dried it over to Austria
and I found myself Vienna International
Airport and I landed that and then I
just showed them my expired passports
and I asked for asylum in the world took
notice
I guess and I would have seen on this
thing like that a bit forward so I think
they liked it I liked it I though then
moved to Los Angeles and built up a
successful airplane propeller business
but even LA couldn't fit his big ideas I
kind of needed a place to this my other
idea which is how to do it in the middle
of the city that's how I found this
place in Utah it was for sale so I
bought it and I've been here for like
eight years
what was I those big idea that brought
him to loosen well it's behind that door
over there inside sits and a propeller
flying machine able to lift off and land
vertically it's basically an airplane
helicopter hybrid of sorts it's kind of
funny looking but the damn thing
actually flies
so what is I those next big project a
solar-powered aircraft another major
innovation in Pella design some kind of
new way to fly the next week one is that
the speargun idea army chalked illy it
looks better than I thought that doesn't
always work that way
sometime I get another bad idea even
while inventing new spear gun from the
light either still find the time to get
out of the house that's him over there
talking to the top of that mountain just
him
nature and his customized rifle I think
the gunner was mean because of the
mountain lions
[Music]
however treacherous the hike it's always
worth it you get a good view loosen it
actually looks pretty nice from here
don't it I wonder why that darkened
butyl ever left maybe loosen wasn't
right for the little guy maybe it
escaped into the next place where it can
be itself
Bravo though looks like this might be
the last stop come at your eyes with
this is hotel whistle on it I kept
escaping until I escaped to listen and
now I don't have anywhere else to escape
I kind of stuck here
[Music]
I don't know about you guys but I both
coal helicopter plane combo buddy built
kind of looks like a drone to me
well that's fitting because our next
story is about a father-son drone racing
duo people could understand that this is
a kin to the scariest thing you've ever
done then they'll start to understand
why we're so addicted to it when I put
the goggles on the first thing I'm doing
is trying to calm down it totally puts
you inside the drone you just forget
where you are I'm Conrad Miller also
known as ferrati and I'm a drum racer I
[Music]
started in September 2014 and that was
like the ground floor
[Applause]
of all the activities I've partaken in
motorcycles and flying drones are on the
same level in terms of intensity it's
cool when you have a hobby and you can
do it and you love it but when you can
share it with your kids I mean that's
just you know it's just like what it's
all about I think
ok so props again flying and racing with
Pharrell has just been a pure joy he's a
good kid he needs a talented kid and I
think it comes in you pet any kid like
that because they don't feel the
pressure that adults do good landing
come in and hat this is harder than
anything else I've done and it's because
when you're when your nerves go your
fine motor skills go kids don't care
there's having fun and they just learn
much faster the course in LA at the
Hawthorne mall which is abandons been
abandoned since the 80s I believe and it
looks like a place where you would go if
there was a zombie apocalypse and to
greated feel like I put a lot of
pressure on myself to win you know I
want all of my practice and all of my
time flying to shelter something I was
flying by and I wasn't nervous but I was
just a little too high and crap you like
all just a feeling
[Music]
everybody is just working really hard to
be the best at it and it's just going to
get tougher and tougher I think that 180
good you kated flying withdrawal now it
kind of gives me an opportunity to look
at it from a different perspective
because I can coach him ready thank you
[Music]
he's aware enough to know that he gets
to do these things that most kids don't
get to do flying a drone which is this
groundbreaking thing we hit each other
you hit me what are you talking about we
hit each other you know as parents we
don't always feel like we do enough I
brought him in the drone racing and he
knows he's lucky and you know he's
fortunate you know kiddo you're going
pretty quick and you know he's just he's
grateful for everything that he get
thanks for watching these four great big
stories with us I hope you had fun
flying around with us click the horse to
subscribe leave a message down below and
we'll see you next time